Speaker 1: Let's get into this week's mailbag.
Email info at David Pakman dot com If you have
a question, comment, criticism, suggestion,
whatever. You also maybe be too, if you leave
a YouTube comment or if you send us a message on
Twitter or Facebook or whatever the case may be.
Let's get right into it because there are so
many interesting messages. I want to start with
a negative message. Yes. Sometimes we start with
something negative and then we move on to positive
things. Clay wrote in with a very aggressive
message, Clay said. GUTFELD kicks every late
night fascist ass maggots to ass. That's why you
whine about him. I can't remember the last time
I mentioned Greg GUTFELD. You whine about vaccines
because your dumb ass is ran to pump the clot shot
you. Now you clowns see that it's killing people
in all ways the perpetual victim. It's not funny,
but at the same time, you're all such
narcissistic, lobotomized morons. You
won't admit your party leaders to you because
liberals are idiots. Now run off and wait for the
impending abortion. Hmm. I guess I do support sell
fuck boarding liberals. This is a sick person.
I feel so bad for people like this because their
lives must just be terrible that they talk like
this, that they're willing to even send messages
to people like this one was by Facebook. You know,
it's like this. We can see this guy's full name
and where he works. And I would even if I thought
stuff like this, which I don't, I would be.
Embarrassed into a hole in the ground. If I ever
sent someone a message like this. And so I feel
bad for these people. I really do. It's more of
a sad thing that they are willing to send messages
like this than anything else. But they exist. And
there are many, many, many of them. But one more
criticism. This one came via email from Wayne.
Wayne said, Are you getting your content from
MSNBC? CNN? You're an idiot. Why? Oh, you are.
It's almost a requirement, folks. If you send hate
mail, you have to have the wrong your. You're an
idiot. My an idiot. You're an idiot if you believe
any of this. Just wait for the speech tonight.
Not. This was about the State of the Union.
Not one word will be the truth. As the Biden
crime family continues to lie about everything.
Gullible low IQ people like you is the reason
they're slowly wrong there. And then it should
be are instead of his slowly letting socialism
take over our country. Wake up idiots. You know,
it's this is this is about being a being a grammar
Nazi. It's if you're accusing me and my audience
of being low IQ and stupid and all these things,
you've got half a dozen grammar errors in a four
line email and you want to call me low IQ. Come
on, guys. And again, it's more of a tragedy.
It's an educational tragedy. But understand,
something is correlating here. As
I've said before, if people learn
media literacy and critical thinking early.
It's like a vaccine against disinformation.
And it's not a shock that some of the people
who have six errors in a four line email
also believe things that aren't true about
everything from vaccines to socialism to
whatever the case may be. It is not a surprise.
It's not being a grammar Nazi. It's noticing.
There are trends here. All right. Bjorn wrote in
about Sarah Huckabee Sanders response to the State
of the Union says, Hey, David, thanks for the
show. I listened to your show February 8th saying
that Sarah Huckabee Sanders response was maybe
the most viable State of the Union response you
heard. To me, it wasn't even a response to the
State of the Union as it didn't really address
anything in the State of the Union. It felt like
a prerecorded Biden is woke and bad and the left
is horrible. Statement vile. Yes. A response.
I don't know. What do you think? You know,
one of the things that Bjorn is right
about and I realized after the fact,
I don't I'd have to listen to it again. I don't
know that Sarah Huckabee Sanders needed to wait
until after the speech to give that speech. What I
mean is she could have recorded the speech before
Biden's State of the Union address and it would
have been just as relevant, irrelevant in reality,
because I think Bjorn is right. I don't know that
anything Biden actually said was addressed. Yes,
socialism and woke and all these different
things. But I don't think that the actual
subject matter of Biden's speech was addressed
by Sarah Huckabee Sanders. I think Bjorn is
absolutely on to something. It really wasn't an
actual response. Matt wrote in and said, David,
sir, I love the new backdrop on the set. You're
the best, Matt. You know, I have to tell you.
On this program any time we've changed anything.
If we're lucky, half the audience is positive
about it. When we change music, we get so many
criticisms. When we've changed set elements,
we get criticisms. When I went to Oh, you know,
now I do wear a tie on the show. Now I'm no
longer wearing a tie. Now I'm not even wearing
the the blazer. I'm back this day. It's always
negative. Our guest hosts negative, which we'll
get to, by the way, this change to the backdrop,
which I believe is a beautiful change, has been
received more positively than anything we have
ever changed on the show, which is great. Makes me
happy. You love to see it. And we've got a couple
other small changes up our sleeve which will be
coming soon. Mikel wrote to me and said, David,
there's something that bugs me when you cover
George Santos in your show. You keep referring to
him as George Anthony Devil Dirt, Katara Santos. I
think you should not include Katara at this point.
What he did in his past as a drag. I think he.
I think Michael means as a drag queen was not
a lie. And he doesn't owe any explanation about
it to anybody. I know you're not asking for that,
but when you keep including that part, when
covering his continuous lies, you make it
look like that's a lie, too. It wouldn't be
a big deal unless homophobes, transphobes and
drag phobes could use that against him, which I'm
afraid can happen. That's why I think you should
limit his name to George Anthony Devil or Santos.
Already long enough without Katara. So I have two
thoughts about this. Number one. Katara is related
to a lie because he said it wasn't him initially,
when the photos came out of Santos in drag, which
is politically relevant because Republicans have
been on a crusade against drag queens in drag
shows and drag time reading out or whatever.
He lied and said that wasn't me, and then later
said, Actually, it was me. So it is part of the
lie. That being said, I've received emails on both
sides of this. I received a few emails like what
Nicolle says, which is it could be sort of seen as
like mildly homophobic or drag phobic or whatever
to include Katara in the name because that
was his drag name. And others who wrote to me,
including people from the LGBT community, who
said, David, he lied about the drag stuff. It's
completely fair to include Katara when you say
George Anthony Katara to Santos, sort of like
Stephen Kenneth Destiny banal. The second I
have stopped using Katara over the last week,
I don't have a strong feeling one way or the
other, but certainly nothing homophobic is
meant by it. John wrote in and said, If Trump
is still president, why does it matter that the
election was stolen? Seems like it wouldn't
matter, right? Great job, David and Luke.
Keep it up. That's from Jon, who also goes by
Mongoose. Yeah, this is one of those, you know.
The January 6th riots were actually totally
peaceful and the rioters were antifa and square,
but so were they peaceful or were they antifa?
It is true. It is true that for the people who
say the election was stolen and also I believe
Trump is still the president, if Trump is still
the president, it wasn't really stolen, was it? If
you believe Trump won. Good luck speaking to these
people. I mean, it's like you're trying to apply
logic to claims that are completely illogical.
So while you're completely correct, I believe it
would be a waste of time to try to confront these
folks with that, but probably entertaining on some
level. Daniel wrote in about My Replacements, my
guest hosts, and said, David, none of these people
comes even close to you. I cannot watch the show
if you're not there. Please don't go away again,
says Daniel. Well, Daniel, I'm sorry to tell you,
I'm going to continue going away. Breaks
are important. Vacations are important. Now,
we've gone over this issue with the guest
hosts, many time with you in the audience.
There was a time when when I was off, there was
no show. Just there were no shows. And a lot of
people didn't like that. There's a David,
you should have someone fill in for you.
We started having people fill in, which
by the way, is a lot more work for us.
And no matter who fills in, I get a ton of emails
saying I didn't like that person. People write in,
they say, I don't like when Luke Beesley fills in.
I prefer Ferran. We have foreign people write in
Farrands Terrible. You should have, you know,
Jesse Dallimore someone else. Jesse Dallimore
fills in for me. Jesse's terrible. He yells too
much. Someone said, You should have Luke do it.
There is not going to be a perfect fit. But I
think there's a couple of takeaways from this.
Number one, it is flattering that me being
gone is upsetting to people in the sense that
there are people that are sort of counting on
the show and like the show enough that when
I'm not here, it's upsetting to them. I find that
beautiful. I think that that's a testament to the
community that we've built here and it's a really
great thing. Now where it gets ugly is the people
who threaten to cancel their memberships if I have
replacement hosts or go on vacation, you know?
If you're telling me you value the show so
much that you want me to be here more and
you're willing to pay for a membership. It
seems a little strange that you would say,
I'm going to stop watching and cancel my
subscription if you take any vacations.
It seems not only insensitive to the
reality that like, Hey, I need brakes too,
but if you love the show so much that you're
furious when I'm gone. Why would you swear
it off and start supporting the show? That's a
little bit of a bummer. But here's the bottom
line. Nobody likes. Not everybody likes any of
the hosts that we have. And after all, it is the
David Pakman show. So it sort of makes sense that
at least in general, you're tuning in to see me.
So I'm very sensitive to that. We are going to
continue a rotating cast of guest hosts that
way. There will be, hopefully someone everybody
likes, and if you only want to see me, then just
don't watch or listen on the days that I'm gone.
I think that's the best solution for everybody.
And most importantly, I really appreciate
everybody who does have a paid subscription.
And when we're off writes in and says, Hey, David.
Just wanted to let you know I'm a paid supporter,
you being gone reminded me how much I like the
show and count on it. Enjoy the time away. Can't
wait to see you when you're back. Those are really
beautiful messages. I get like three whenever I'm
away. Okay, we have a great bonus show for you
today. Sign up. It joined Apple.com. We'll see it.